hello everyone and welcome back to this
ggplot2 webinar can I get a quick
feedback on whether you can hear me and
see me okay
otherwise I'll just be assuming
[Music]
it seems to be working fantastic okay
welcome everyone welcome back I am happy
that a lot of people decided to join me
once again for this ggplot2 webinar as I
told you last time this is the corona
edition of a webinar that I was giving
at the celebration celebration
conference that was just like a month
ago or something like that so last time
we we had quite a lot of fun looking
into this theory about around the
grammar of graphics and also how it
applied to to actual the API of ggplot2
and and will continue had fast into New
Territories a day if there are any new
viewers just quickly about me my name is
Thomas Liam Peterson I'm a software
engineer our studio where I am
responsible partly for ggplot2 but
generally just everything graphics when
it comes to through our packages from
our studio I was once a bioinformatician
but I've been moving away from that
obviously I block on data imaginisce I'm
Twitter on Thomas P 58 85 and I'm also
on github under the same username though
I don't think actually I talked about
the picture on the on the right that is
made with ggplot2 by me so never feel
ggplot2 constraining you like you can
you can draw almost whatever you want if
you if you correctly figure out how to
decompose the the problem so so about
today or also about what happened last
time we talked about the grammar of
graphics and we talked about how
was reflected in the ggplot2 api the
reason why we had such a long webinar
last time I think it ended up being two
and a half hours is that I think the
theory is super important to actually
understand why we do things the way we
do in G to plot - and the reason why is
important to understand why we do things
the way we do in G to plot - is that
there's a theoretical backbone to it and
and once you understand the logic of
that theoretical backbone you don't
really need to understand everything and
everything seen in ggplot2 because you
can kind of understand the logic to it
and you know where to look for more
information so having these two together
like the the underlying theory of
grammar of graphics along with how that
is reflected in the API is super
important I think which is why I I
decided to check them together into one
quite long hole so today we will be
moving beyond ggplot2 did put - is a
huge beast we didn't talk about every
possible function last time there are a
lot to be done but but I hope that you
can see how you can look into that
yourself and pretty easily understand
all these different aspects of it and
today we'll be moving into like the
extended universe of ggplot2 which is
the extension mechanisms that ggplot2
exposes allows other packages to build
upon the ggplot2 API and I'll be I'll be
talking mainly about that aspect and the
last part will be kind of a metre
discussion part where I kind of show a
bit at how you can think with the
grammar of graphics in mind and how you
can use that not to figure out how to
how to make new graphics but also how we
can use it to actually inspect already
made graphics and maybe even be better
at understanding what's been show to
show to you same our device as last time
there are things that we will not talk
about in this this way
you know will not talk about how to get
data into will not talk about data
manipulation will not talk about our
programming there are a lot of things
that are important when when it comes to
to doing data visualization that are
related related to data import data
manipulation and general programming but
that's that is for another webinar
possibly by someone else but thankfully
there is a lot of free material online
these are some of the different packages
that are central to to a lot of people
working with this and they all have
excellent web pages that you can browse
into and when it comes to our
programming hadley has been been making
some fantastic books that are all
available for free that you can dive
into so so go nuts don't go nuts right
now because I want you to stay and
listen to this but afterwards if you
feel like you're lagging in some aspects
in these areas then definitely go check
out these different resources as last
time there is a github repository for
the work this workshop I think I've been
4-sided and actually put this link in
the description of this video this time
I'm still learning as we go
when it comes to streaming but otherwise
you can visit list this link where you
can download and an hour markdown file
that you can open in in our studio or
whatever you you prefer to to run your
our code and we can just have a quick
look at it you can see over here there
will be for all the different
plus I'm going to show you I'll let you
also show you the code generated for the
plus and that code is also reflected in
this exercises pad so you can go along
executing the code be be sure that I'm
not lying to you that it actually works
and actually produces the plot that I'm
showing to you and then after each short
section there will be some exercises and
usually in a in a workshop you'll have
some time to sit down and dive into the
exercises and tries to to solve them
that doesn't really work here I think so
so I will try to live code them and and
if you want to solve them yourself you
can you can mute me look away and you
can try to solve them at another time at
your own convenience you can also just
follow along and then let some days pass
and then try to solve them yourself it's
been so long since I made these
exercises that I have absolutely
forgotten everything about them so you
will see actual live live coding where
tries to figure out what I actually
wanted to do at the time at the time
when I made these exercises so there
will be no cheating or anything yes so
let's get back to the slides so the meet
of today will will focus on what I call
beyond ggplot2 how you can move beyond
what did you plot to allows you to do
using a lot of the different extension
packages already available I didn't talk
about this in the intro but I don't
expect this this webinar taught to to be
as as long as the last time it's
probably going to be between one and one
and a half hour or something like that
but we'll see I honestly don't know but
there won't be as much material as last
time I have the same amount of water as
last time and I expect it to hold out so
big question with when we're talking
about extension this is really why
extensions like why don't you just add
more more features into into ggplot2
like that would be nice and we wouldn't
have to go looking for different
extensions to solve our problems the
reason for that is mainly that jeepers
too is huge as it is and and just
maintaining the the current state of
affair is a team effort it is mainly
being handled by by me and Klaus Wilker
and Yuri Dunnington and you hockey and
I'm sorry I can't pronounce his take I'm
sorry I and and a few others kara was
also part of the core team and headley
is sometimes doing a bit of work but not
a lot and as it is it's quite huge for
writer like my last count we had 47
teams we have 25 stats and we have 62
scales so there's a lot of functionality
buildings to that already and
furthermore we were actually constantly
evolving the the internals of ggplot2
and and we'd rather focus on that making
sure that the internals are sound and
safe and let let other people focus on
new and fancy features
hadley actually shared with me like the
I think the announcement for GG plot 2
version 1 lately where he talked about
that the this version number
Diablo 2 was famously a 0.9 version for
the first I don't know 10 years of
existence or something like that and
then suddenly it actually hit the the
1.0 version mark and when you release
that he told and told me or he told the
the users that well this reflects that
the GD plot 2 is now actually in a
stable format and very little
development will will be put into it
from that one and he has he has been
wrong before and he was definitely wrong
this time
because there is a lot of development
going into ggplot2 core as it is looking
into how we can improve the existing
functionality and especially how we can
allow extension developers to do more so
so ggplot2 is definitely not dead in any
sense of the word and it just keeps
growing so there's a lot of extensions
out there and many extensions are quite
specific to a certain niche and this is
also one of the reason why we feel it's
it's better than that
first within this niche well will focus
on developing things that are specific
to them instead of letting us who may
not know so much about this these
different types of visualizations take
decisions that may not be optimal for
for these types of visualizations so so
it's it's way better to have have a
distributed development of new features
and and make these new features be
developed by people who really really
care about this this area further it's
also quite a lot easier to promote new
focus packages instead of just having a
continuous stream of updates about
what's new and ggplot2 like having blog
post for this new fancy extension
packages is way better to to actually
describe new features a lot of the the
fitti or a lot of the extension packages
has been has been collected into a into
a gallery and this gallery is not
maintained by by the other core team in
any in any regard but there were some
problems with the with the domain of the
last address for the site so it has
changed location a bit so now we are we
have we have allowed it to be host under
the ggplot2 that tidy versatile org
domain so you can now find it an X that
ggplot2 that tidy verse talk and and
you'll find a lot of the different
different extension packages listed
there this is a on and an opt-in basis
so if you're developing extensions you
can you can create a pull request for
this this website and have your
extension listed there but it it will
not just pick up any new extension pages
there so it's not complete in any in any
sense but a lot of the the bacons and
very very thorough extension packages
are listed there and it's a great way to
just look in to see well what's actually
possible at this moment so the first
thing I'm going to talk about is plot
composition and if you remember the last
time we talked a bit about fair
and and how how people have tried to use
fascist for composing multiple very very
different plus together and also alluded
to the fact that this was not the the
best way to do it because newer and
better ways of doing this as has
appeared but why even do plot
composition
well mainly because when you want to
tell stories with data visualization
it's very very seldom that you can just
create a single plot that will tell the
full story sometimes it's okay to have
like multiple separate plus its wine
with text and so on but sometimes you
also want to have like a complete story
told by multiple smaller plots all tied
together in a single visualization and
and this is really like this is blood
composition and you want to be able to
do that with whatever type of plotting
frame wedding would you want to do this
is not something this is not a new
demand as I talked about people have
tried to do it with with the facet had a
hacking but there has also been a lot of
different approaches throughout the
years grid extra has set a greater range
function that some people are still
using Gigi Papa has a Gigi arranged cow
plot as a plot Chris function all these
are just simply trying to combine
multiple plus into an appealing
composition in some way because I'm me
and I am ruling what I'm talking about
I will overrule all of these and talk
about patchwork which is one of my own
packages and I truly believe it's the
it's the best way to do plot
conversation but I will not force you to
use it in any regard like if you if
you're already using Gigi para or Cal
plot or whatever and and feel like that
is is the best way for you to do it
certainly continue to use that I will
say though that that if you haven't used
any of these packages to do plot
composition before and and wants to
start doing that I will definitely
recommend patchwork it's the most recent
one and also quite sure it's the most
feature complete one
so how does it look well when we're
doing blood composition we need some
multiple different plots to kind of show
off so so here's one kind of boring plus
showing the amount of sleep by by
different different types of I guess
it's mammals I can't really remember the
sleep patterns have different mammals
depending on whether the meat eaters or
sexy horse or whatever I will just
create a couple of different plus two
this so not really anything interesting
there and you will probably see as if
you remember from last time these plus
that I'm showing I'm not meant to be
stunning in like the inside that you're
getting out of it there Mon mainly you
used to kind of show what I'm talking
about so keep that in mind so if we have
these three different plots that I just
showed you and we want to combine them
into a single plot using patchwork how
would we go about doing that well it's
actually quite simple because patch
works kind of claims to fame is that it
it extends the use of the plus operator
and as you will see in a minute some
some additional operators to actually
just allow you to add plots together now
this is a horrible plot right I can
absolutely see that this is not the best
selling point for patchwork because it
looks horrible the reason why it looks
horrible is that there are simply not
enough space for for our panels in this
area that we're looking at because the
three legends are taking out a fixed
amount of space and the different exit
sticks is taking up a fixed amount of
space and there's only so much space and
now plus so it doesn't look good but
it's not the full of the packages it was
trying to fill out the area that it's
been giving we can improve on that a bit
by for instance tagging two of them on
top of the other one and as you can see
there are a different a couple of
different operators that allows us to
actually do quite elaborate layouts of
plus
with a very little amount of coat so so
what we see here is that besides the
plus operator which actually is just as
plus together and place them in a grid
and that grid can have a number of
columns and a number of rows we can also
use the the type of razor to to stack or
to position plus beside each other so so
they will always be placed beside each
other and we can use the division
operator to stack something on top of
each other and as you can see you're
able to actually nest plus down there
using these things so the the 2 plus on
top is a nested pass work which is then
stacked on top of the the other plot
what patchwork is it's really good at
doing is that it is absolutely enforcing
that the flooding areas of the different
plus stay aligned no matter how how
complex your your nesting structure and
your your composition ends up being it
will always align the plus when I say a
line is simply aligning the plot area so
know as you can see the top left plot
has it has a y-axis with some long long
labels and we can see that that doesn't
inflict on how it it's aligned with the
bottom part of the plot which has only
20 15 10 and 5 assists as its axis text
so everything will always stay aligned
no matter what you throw at let's say
there's a question here I'll try to see
if I can pick up questions as we go
there's one asking whether we can use
patchwork for plus generated without did
you put two and yes you can I don't
think I have any any examples of that
right now but but you can use it with
base package plots as well and you can
also simply add different grid objects
together so you can make
a table using great extra with the table
crap and stick it together with with
your with your figure if you want to so
so you can actually kind of catch
everything that you that you want to
plot and use it with password all that
being said ggplot2 is quite different
from from how base plot is working so
the alignment is not really possible to
to do when you're for instance if you're
if you're combining a GU plot to plot
with base plot it's not possible to have
it automatically align everything
patchwork is taking making a lot of
assumptions assumptions are okay because
I'm developing ggplot2 so I know the
assumptions that are okay about how the
structure of a G plot to plot looks and
and it uses that to ensure that they are
always aligned okay
so what can we do otherwise well if we
have this plot composition that we saw
before there is a lot of space wasted in
the main area because we want we have
this this alleged in the middle of all
all the things and and what patchwork is
actually able to do is that is able to
say collect all the guides and place
them to the side now once more you can
see that well we don't have enough space
to actually show the the legends right
now they get capped in the
that's up again this is not really patch
boys fall is just me being sloppy when I
formatted the pictures but as you can
see it allows a lot of quite nice
dynamic things to happen but this
particular set up we can actually see
that we don't need any legends at all
because the two top plots are actually a
kind of legend because we see the colors
I match to the sort of y-axis so we
don't really need any
in code at all and we can we can turn
that off and what I'm showing you here
is a new operator which is the am
percent and the am percent allows you to
add ggplot2 elements like theme or geom
whatever to all of the all of the sub
plants plots in your patchwork so we can
quite easily and with absolutely minimal
code turn off the the legend to all of
our sub plus in one single line so
that's quite nice as well and suddenly
we can see that we can actually show all
these three plots quite nicely in a in a
single single area now usually when you
when you do this maybe not usually but a
lot of time when you're doing this it's
because its intended to go into some
sort of articles so if you're if you're
in academia you will usually have
figures in your articles and a lot of
these figures are actually multiple
smaller plus and you will want to
identify these smaller plus so can you
do that with password what you can so we
can do all sorts of plot annotations to
the final the final plot final patchwork
we can add a tour a title to all the
things together and we can also
automatically check the the plus in
there and so right now we say tech
levels equals uppercase a which means
that it will use uppercase letters to to
tack them we can also we're going to
stuck in a lowercase a and it will use
lowercase we're stuck in a a 1 and we'll
use numerals or an eye to use Roman
numerals uppercase eyes use other case
known Roman numerals and so on so so
it's quite flexible and how you can
actually take this
[Music]
further it actually allows you to dive
into the nested structure of your
patchwork so so for instance in this
example we have the two upper plots are
a nested patchwork inside a bigger
patchwork so we could we could add
multiple tech levels and say well the
top left plot would be a one and top
right plus will be a two and the button
plot will be B instead and actually
provides facilities to do all that
automatically as well so it does a lot
of things that allows you to generate
this this figure composition completely
inside our instead of having to go into
other image editing software to to add
all the different things that you need
to which is nice post both because it it
simplifies a lot of things but also
makes everything more reproducible right
so let's see can we use plot layout
globally like do you plug theme said no
you cannot right now I think that you
can I have been contemplating on whether
you should be able to set these things
somewhere globally either using options
or using other facilities like like with
theme sets so that might appear in in a
later release and someone is asking why
what is the reason for not using the
plus operator for the theme let us talk
about the am percent will will apply the
the object to all of the different
subplots so if you only use the plus
operator it will apply it only to the
last plot in the in the patchwork but
with the ampersand it will actually go
into each and every every plot in your
composition and you can also manipulate
the position of tech level letters this
is not a this is actually not a password
feature as such ggplot2 supports
supports the tag element natively so you
can add attack using to you plug so
and this is simply what what patchwork
is automating so so there are theme
settings and ggplot2 that allows you to
to modify the different things and can
you align the title in the middle with
patchwork you can also do that you can
do that as well you can have a patchwork
level theme and you can have themes
settings for the different different
plus as well okay let's move on before
we go to animations we should look into
the different exercises that I have
maybe I will actually answer some of
your your questions with the exercises
as well as I said I can't really
remember what the exercises are okay so
let's see what I've been thinking about
patchwork we'll assign the same amount
of space to each plug by default but
this can be controlled with the width
and height argument and flood layout
this can take a numeric work so gave
them their relative sizes he chooses to
one will make the first plot twice as
big as the second so modify the code
below so that the middle plot takes up
half of the total space so let's see
what do we have here oh I was starting
from a fresh session and I also have no
password so the joy of life coding right
okay let's see we have a single plot and
we'll do will simply combine it with
itself that's right boring but just for
illustrative purposes so if I want to
control the relative sizes of the
different plots I can do that with the
plot layout function as you can see
there's quite a lot of different
different arguments to this and a love
that can just be ignored but let's see
if we say with with equals see
to want we can see that the middle plot
will actually be twice as big as the as
the outer plus and the the thing that
gets bigger is simply the flood area so
it will never penalize a plot that has
very very wide y-axis for instance it
will simply make sure that the plot area
and the panel is twice as big as as the
others right so I think one other thing
that that is possible to do is that with
can also be a unit mixer let's see so
instead of of just using numerix we can
actually set maybe potentially one of
the plots to have a fixed size like five
centimeters from whatever so if we see
is it unit see the unit function is from
Grif and you may stumble upon it when
you're working with G to plot in general
as well so let's see I'm going off
script right now so let's see
centimeters maybe that's way too big I
don't know and null simply means fill
out the remaining area okay
so so now the five the the first plot
will have a fixed width of 5 centimeters
no matter how we kind of resize the
total plotting area it will stay 5
centimeters and the remaining plus will
then just split the remaining area
between them okay let's see there are
some questions coming up I recently had
problems when using patch work to
combine plots where one uses called
fixed when I try to give them different
width yeah so aligning fixed plots is is
tree and
work supports it to some extent but it
will try to try to do the right thing
but basically if you have a grid of
plots and maybe the middle one has a has
a fixed as a fixed size and the total
like the total flood area has another
aspect ratio or whatever like you you
have to figure out where to where to
concede because you cannot solve this
optimally in all cases so sometimes it
will it will shrink the plot to maintain
the aspect ratio that it requires which
will then resolve in it not being
aligned with the other plus but it will
try its utmost to avoid doing that but
but in the in the end if it cannot do
that it will try it will simply shrink
it and maybe you've had problems because
you you ended up setting your plot in
such a way that that it simply could not
figure out a solution to it like it's
it's basically a linear linear problem
solution and then sometimes these don't
have these don't have solutions so yes
what's the next thing the ampersand
operator can be used with any type of
ggplot2
object not just themes usually it's used
with themes because you want to modify
the theme to everything at once but it
can be used with whatever type of
ggplot2 object that you're usually
adding with with plus so um oh sorry I
don't know what happened there so here
we have two plots and as we can see
these are aligned in the sense that the
panel area takes up the same amount of
space what it hasn't been doing is
aligning the actual values of of the
of the axis and it's it's not doing that
for for very good reasons maybe there
will be some automatic thing in the
future but but basically it's not always
that you want to align the exes a lot of
times the the exes are not comparable in
any way so you don't want to align it
right now if you want to align this you
could do that by by adding the same
scale of why continues and setting the
limits to something that kind of
fulfills oh sorry that that fulfills
what both of them needs so so the lower
one in the left plot is it's ten and the
upper one is oh let's just say forty to
be in the same side and as we can see it
has gone in and then applied the same
scale Y scale to both of the plots and
since they take up the same amount of
space it means that all the tick marks
are now actually aligned okay let's see
patchwork contains many features for
fine-tuning the layout and annotation
very complex layout can be obtained by
providing a design specification to the
design document in plot layout and the
design can be defined as a textual
representation of the cells so we use
the layout below how should the textual
representation be understood okay so we
create three plus once more and then we
we have this this layout which is just a
text that is giving kind of a matrix of
a BBC and instead of instead of doing
nesting or whatever instead of doing
something fails we simply say as a
design for this plot used to layer and
as we can see here I hope you can
understand what is happening the first
plot is placed inside the AAA
area so this layout defines a 3 x 3
matrix and the 2
Chapra the two left top most cells will
be used for the for the a and the middle
to right most cells were used for the
for the second plant and the single
bottom button lift area will be used for
the for the last plug and everything
that has this since in all carats of the
the comment character and our at least
was simply be ignored and and these like
a PMC is not enough something special
you can use numbers as well if you want
to like that and we will get the same
result
hopefully yes we did so it's simply like
it arranges the different values
alphabetically alphabetic numerically I
think so what what if it makes it let's
just see so a will be the first one yet
and and then two and three okay anyway
so you can see that that it's possible
to to create quite complex compositions
with this right so sometimes if you want
something truly complex instead of doing
a lot of nesting and and so on it might
be better to simply just define the
layout either using this layout
specification but you can also you can
also do it with say and now I have
absolutely forgotten what is called you
can make these area calls and simply
just combine them with C so area from
the top one to the
the first left and I'll try I'm thinking
while I'm having right now so sorry
about that
so for instance this area here will will
mean that it will go from the top the
top cells it will occupy from 1 to 1 in
the the grid and when it comes to 2 rows
and it will occupy from 1 to 2 in the
grid when it comes to columns so this is
the same as the a up here right and you
can just combine them together won't
talk about this um ok that's it so
there's a lot of things that you can do
with pass work I haven't even talked
about all of the things but but just
rest assured that you can you can spend
a lot of time function in your your
compositions and you can usually avoid
having to spend time in an external
program ok
so let's jump over to the next thing
so animations why animations there's a
lot of old and boring people who will
probably say that animations are just
fat and it's just a shim and no one
should use it because a nice static
visualization is all you ever need
well maybe a nice static visualization
is is usually sufficient and maybe it is
usually the most correct way of showing
data but if you want to if you want to
do storytelling and especially if you
want to grab attention of of people then
animations are absolutely amazing so for
instance on Twitter or LinkedIn or
whatever if something is moving like the
eye is fine-tuned to detect movement and
you cannot look away like it is a
fantastic way to grab the attention of
people and like the the most perfect
visualization is just meaningless if no
one is looking at it so there's like
there's nothing bad about wanting to
grab
people's attention it is absolutely
critical when it comes to one aims to
tell your story that people are actually
listening so being able to make
animations and being able to make data
animations is is it's quite crucial when
you want to to tell stories and thought
about it major enough some people like
some people will will discard you as I'm
serious when it comes to data
visualization when you're employing
animations don't listen to them because
it has it has value and this has a
reason there are many ways to to make
animations in our there are the animate
page where you simply just create
multiple plots like one plot per frame
in your animation and it will stick it
together there's also a page called
movies i I think Gigi animate is I think
the only way to do that in a in a
grammar way so so Gigi animate is not
simply a wrapper around ggplot2 it is an
extension of is an extension of the
grammar that ggplot2 is based upon so
kind of extended to talk about
animations and as such it it works quite
seamlessly with the gnew plot too and
and it can be kind of hard to see where
do you put two stops and Judea animate
begins because it simply provides new
grammar elements to add to your plot and
it ended it then takes over the
rendering of the of the plus so it's not
static anymore but it's actually moving
so if we have a static plot like this
boring economic data one of the one of
the ways to make animation is is to have
a line appear as it as it goes through
time so this is a prime example that and
and the way that Gigi anime works is by
providing especially a new type of
object
all transitions which defines how how
the the layer data should be interpreted
in the sense of in the sense of of
animations so for instance here we we
add a transition rear-wheel and we say
well it should be revealed along the
date variable and as we're using the
date variable in our assumed line for
the exit etic what we see is actually
that we have an animation that simply
shows the line appearing as a state is
it's increased now that is very very
little line of a few lines of code that
needs to be added to actually make an
animation and I think it's it's quite
powerful in a sense that if you have if
you already have it you plot to object
making it move in some sense and in some
ways it's extremely easy to do and it
does not uh does not make you exit that
that Grammer idea that you already have
in your in your head you can do you kind
of stay in a grammar world and the only
thing that you have to think about is
that well we have extended like Rama now
to also talk about animations our
transitions are not the only the only
things that that Gigi animate as to the
to the mix if we look at this super
interesting poplar where we just see the
amount of of casts that have different
numbers numbers of cylinders maybe we
want to cycle through the years of the
camels in this data set there are two
years now what we can do is we're adding
a bit more interesting things to the
fact here but what we can see is we're
using a new transition this time is
called transition States kind of like a
discrete scale in the sense that it
defines defines that some different
states here based on year and it's
simply just cycles through them and we
can see that the past move depending on
how many there were in the different
years as we have a situation where one
of the year there are no
there are no five gear and five
cylinders are cars at all we have to let
a graphic element disappear somehow and
into somehow and what we the way we
specify this is by using insert and exit
functions so we can see when when new
data new graphic objects comes into the
visualization or the animation we will
will use grow into grow and when they go
out we'll just fade them away and as you
can see that's exactly what's happening
one more thing is that Gigi animate also
allows you to update the different
titles subtitles captions and so on in
your plot using using plural notation if
you're not aware of the glue package
it's a it's a package that allows stream
literal interpretation in our so the
title and we set up here number of cars
in and then these curly brackets closest
state curly brackets in by number of
cylinders everything that's contained
within these curly brackets will be
evaluated as as our code and and will be
inserted in the string now what is
closest state well the different
transitions actually provide different
different variables throughout the
animations that these these laps all
these titles will be evaluated against
so transition states will provide for
instance closest state which is the the
name of the state that is closest in
times the visualization transition
states have both like fixed fixed parts
of the animation where it just stays in
the state and it has moving parts where
it kind of moves between States and
closest state will always just return
the state that is closest to it there's
also a next state there's also a
previous state and so on so you can you
can modify your your labels and update
them quite quite nicely so I hope it's
it's obvious to you that just with these
two examples
Jiji enemy it allows a lot of customer
station and a lot of very very different
types of animation and it kind of takes
this idea of a grammar and breaks it
into the animation world in the sense
that you don't need to support a fixed
amount of different animation types you
just provides the different grammar
objects and they will just kind of work
together seamlessly and allows you to
define new types of animations okay so
let's just take some questions now
[Music]
okay okay so there's one thing from from
Padua I'll just briefly give you what
would be the approach to per map the
plus operator to a list of Gigi plots so
patchwork provides a wrap plots function
where you can just stick in a list of
Gigi plus and it will basically apply
the plus operator to it like that so so
that is usually what you want to do if
you have if you use patchwork in a
functional sense we don't know how many
plus will be provided in the end so how
did it at text a long plus and okay I
don't really understand that the
animation is not showing up in my Mac
down so maybe you need to install
[Music]
install some packages for this to work
we can talk about that later
so can you save Gigi animate outputs in
a file and you can do that so
interestingly Gigi animate when it
describes the animation it keeps it
unrendered and it is only when you when
you view the animation that it's
actually rendered and the way it's
rendered is the way it's rendered is
based on the renderer that you define
and there's a there's a gif ski render
that uses the gif Ski Package to to
combine pictures together into a gif
there's also support for AV which can
make movies like MP MP for movies and
whatnot and there's also support for
making
sprite-based animations and whatever so
that's up to you your needs and wishes
so can you combine different animations
using patchwork this is something that
is being asked quite a lot and you
cannot right now but that will come I
happen to be the developer of both
packages and this is an obvious need
that was intended from the beginning
it's just a matter of me having time to
actually implement it so let's let's
look at some of the exercises um so the
animation below will animate between
parts showing casts with different
silver cylinders so let's just average
in you animate
okay so animations unfortunately are not
instantaneous a big part of what I'm
doing at ggplot2 is to improve the the
rendering engine of graphics in our in
general and that will spill over to
animations as well but but as you can
see right now it will render everything
in one go and then we will then it will
show it I'm actually I am unsure why
it's not showing in inside the markdown
file that I thought that was working
maybe it's a new version of amok down
anyway we have the we have the
visualization over here so let's just
maximize that okay so this is not a good
visualization right or it's not a good
good animation so let's just get down to
them so what we're looking at is that we
have we have different casts and we're
showing the the highway yield and the
displacement of these different casts
and we will move between the different
casts with different cylinders and then
we can see the points are moving between
the states
which is kind of implying that the same
car suddenly have four cylinders and now
the moving things have five cylinders
and now they have six cylinders and this
is not true like these are distinct
casts and you don't want to to move the
different points when it's not like
being the same object that you're
looking at right so how do we how do we
fix that
well Gigi animate uses the group
aesthetic that all that's already
present in the engine you plot to to
figure out whether whether an object is
the same across space and that's that's
quite important to remember because
usually if you don't specify the group
aesthetic and you don't have any
different color or whatever you have to
you don't really need to specify that
the group aesthetic will just be set to
minus one for all the rows which means
that TJ animate will think that that
these point all belongs to the same kind
of underlying data observation and it
will move them around so we can get a
better visualization by actually
specifying the group and we will just
specify it to something like so we'll
just give every every point is to own
unique group right let's just see how
that looks
hopefully something will pop up yes
and what we see now here is that there
is no like movement of points between
the different frames which is actually
what we want because each point shows a
distinct observation not from the same
cast and so on and usually we can fine
tune this by it by adding enter and exit
statements so we have them fade in and
fade out or whatnot but basically this
is what we want and when I'm looking at
animations in the wild this is usually
where people kind of forget to think
about what the animation is actually
conveying if you don't have the same
underlying object that you're
representing you shouldn't have that the
graphical object move between states
right now sometimes you don't have to
think about that because sometimes
ggplot2 will will add the group for you
[Music]
if you for instance add back a color at
the street color mapping then the group
will be based on that color mapping so
if we say color factor so then the then
the sorry I lost my track there then the
group aesthetic will be derived from
from this cylinder factor and actually
end up being as we wanted as well so it
is it's not always you have to specify
the group aesthetic which is kind of
annoying but but you should always think
about it right I will just let that
think a bit and I just answer the next
the next exercise so sorry about that
let's see if it's overdone
this is not the best selling point for a
gentleman right now right there we go
I don't think my streaming software's
doing anything person to - the - how
long it takes so anyway you can see here
it actually behaves as we wanted to
behave again now because each point will
will not have the same ID across states
anyway so there'll be no movement of the
points okay and this was what the second
exercise was all about so in the
animation below as in all other
animations the change happened at
constant speed having said constant
speed how values change during an
animation is called easing and can't be
controlled using the ECS function read
the documentation for EC as an
experiment with different ease things in
the animations so we'll just while that
is happening we can't do that maybe we
can look into help
so easiest it's a kind of a whip concept
and then you will it'll make more sense
when you when you look at it but as you
can have seen when we saw the movement
of the points for instance they are
moving at constant speed and that is
usually not that that pleasing right
because they suddenly stop and they
suddenly start and this is kind of of
putting sometimes at least so what we
can do is that we can say well the why
is that ik should not move at constant
speed we will say it should move in a
cubic in our easing which means that it
will kind of slowly ramp up with speed
and slowly slowly go down and speed
again and all the different aesthetics
can have it's their own easing if you
want to where you can just set the
default easing for everyone to use
[Music]
while it is animating we can just have
some questions how does that animate
deal with multiple layers for example
movement path of animals on a map does
it render the map for each frame yes it
does it is treating it is treating each
thing each frame separately but what it
doesn't do is that it is not calculating
each frame as a separate plot so it is
it is reusing as much as it can but it
will be rendering the the map each time
but it will try to minimize the amount
of work it has to do over and over again
how can someone regulate the speed of
the animation with Gigi anim so what we
see here when we just type the type the
the plot out and it will print it will
just render something and will take a
fixed amount of time and what is
actually happening is that when you
print it in the same way as it when you
when you print a ggplot2 object it will
actually plot it it will call the plot
function
what what what happens with DG animate
objects is that it will call the animate
function and the animate function has a
lot of functionality so when when you're
when you're just printing the TG animate
object it will just use the default
method methods and we can see here that
there is a plot object and then we have
a number of frames frames per second and
duration in seconds so you have to
specifies two of these if you specify
three of these one of them will be
ignored
you can also there something called
detail which means that it will actually
render more frames than needed and only
only show a number of them and here we
can also see that there's a renderer
argument where you can pass in different
renderers for instance the gift key
render or the magic render or the a/v
render or ffmpeg render and so on and
you can have a pause at the a at the
start you can have a pause at the end
you can make it really wide when it's
done and so on I'm not getting any of
the GG animate + 2 works try to rush
this advice I cannot I kind of
troubleshoot during this but if you have
trouble making anything of this work
then please just open an issue in GG
animate and we can figure that out okay
how do you make our show how far it is
with the animation so as we talked about
there is these for instance the closest
state that we had in over here that we
can begin put in but did you animate
also a respectable of any transition
you're using provide something like the
index of the frame or the progression
between 0 & 1 which you which you can
use to show how long you are there are
no kind of progress bar currently this
is something I'm looking into adding so
you can have kind of like a like a guy
that just acts as a progress bar
okay let's just get back to Gigi animate
and back to the exercise okay as we can
see now instead of actually moving
linearly we can see that the plot will
take up speed and then slow down again
which is often much nicer to to look at
especially if if the points are not
moving along a time axis if they're
moving along a time axis then you
usually want them to move at constant
speed because they won't they need to
represent that time truth truthfully
okay and we done with animations okay so
this is just a very very quick sneak
peek into Gigi animated it's quite a
beast of a package and it has quite a
lot of different transitions and I'm
planning on adding more transitions as
for the next version as well so you're
not limited to the view that we're
already so someone asked about batchat
races you can do that as well and you
can do other stuff stuff as well so so
like the the road is opened for you to
to explore different types of animations
based on G plot two setups one thing
that is particularly nice for
presentations for instance is that you
can you can have a transition filter
where you where you have for each state
in the transition you have a specific
filter expression for your data and
we'll just show the data that that
actually that it can actually fulfill
that filtering statement and you can
also add layers gradually and whatnot so
there's a lot of possibilities there
okay so annotations while we are at the
storytelling this has been kind of the
the overarching themes with the
extensions at this point in time it's
difficult to store to tell stories when
you don't use worse and and you can of
course have titles and subtitles and
chintz and so on where you can put in a
lot of words but annotations are simply
[Music]
annotations are simply much more
powerful like pointing something out on
a figure with text and potentially other
stuff is super super impactful when you
want to draw attention to something and
and often when you want it to do like
beautiful beautiful annotation with
ggplot2 you and you ended up exporting
it as a maybe an SVG file or whatnot and
then open it in for instance Adobe Adobe
Illustrator and this is okay of course
and if you enjoy doing that or if you're
kind of forced to do that because you
want to do something that what I'm going
to show you cannot really do then that
is fine but we also end up in this non
reproducible state that we that we saw
with pluck conversation as well so the
more we can move things into code the
better and recent improvements means
that we can move a lot of this into it's
a code I'm going to talk about two key
packages for this at least when it comes
to texture annotation this is Gigi
rappel and the pegs called Gigi force
which is not only about annotation this
is kind of a crap bag of different
things but it provides some very very
cool things to do with with text items
Asians so this is quite a an octave plot
but I think it's a quite common
situation to find yourself in so we have
some points and we want to show what
points are what like we have some
subjects that identify these points and
we want to show what it is right this
looks horrible because there are so over
flooding and there's way too much text
on top of each other it's simply
ineligible now GG ripple provides some
new giome text and giome label gyms
which will try to kind of move labels
they do not overlap out what I'm showing
you here is obviously not a beautiful
plot there's still way too much text
here but just to show that it is that is
able to quite efficiently figure out we
have to put the different labels in a
manner so there so it minimizes
overlapping and it will by itself draw
these these lines back to the origin
point if the labels move away a certain
amount of space and now this is this
dynamic mind you so so if you resize the
plot the labels will be moved around so
so it will up to man optimally place the
labels in the current situation and
usually when you try to do text
animations or a text annotation story
you don't want to annotate everything
anyway like you want to annotate maybe a
few interesting points that you want to
tell a story about and TG repel can also
help with that in the sense that if you
simply said if you simply set the label
of things that you don't want to label
to an empty string they will still kind
of be there and and GG repel will make
make sure that you do not overlap the
points that they are looking for they
link to so you can have maybe show a
couple of points and make sure that the
labels for these points do not overlap
any of the points that that doesn't have
any labels so that's quite nice now
sometimes you're not as much interested
in single points you may be interested
in groups of points and GG force which
is also one of my packages has some
really nice features for this so there
is a family of Mark jims
this one's called with one wish looking
at right now is called Jim Macky lips
there's also a Jim Mac so there's a Jim
Mark Richt and there's a team Mac Howe
and they all kind of do the same but
they simply using different kind of in
closings to to do the same so dear Mac
ellipse will calculate the the minimum
and closing ellipse for all the points
that you want to show
and let's just walk through the code
actually so we have a ggplot and we are
using empty cars and we are mapping
displacement to the x-axis and miles per
gallon to the y-axis and we're having
we're using Jim points to show the
actual points then now comes the GM mark
ellipse call and an inside the aesthetic
we have a filter aesthetic which means
that only only mark the points that has
gear equal four and then there's a label
aesthetic that is this simply gives it a
title and we can also add like more text
with the description cache with fewer
ears tend to have higher yield and lower
displacement right so what we will do is
as we talked about it will calculate the
minimum enclosing ellipse for this point
and drawl and lips around it and it will
actually expand the ellipse just a bit
so it makes sure that the line will not
go over the the points inside the
ellipse further it will create this nice
text box and it will create this nice I
think is statically placing a link to
these of the original data and this text
box is actually placed in the in a
manner so it will not overlap any of the
other points and s with JIRA pill it
will move around as you kind of update
the the aspect ratio and the size of the
plot and you can have you can have
multiple multiple ellipses within the
same visualization and the different
text boxes will never overlap with each
other as well
so you can be confident that that the
look will not require further tweaking
with inside and under software right so
this is quite nice to see oh and as we
talked about there are other types so if
you want to use a circular marking
instead we can do that and and if you
want to have a convex or concave
all around the points you can do that as
well okay so let's dive into the
exercises there we go so Gigi rappel has
a lot of settings for controlling how
text labels move and often it's the most
effective thing is simply to not label
everything and there are two strategies
for that either only use a subset of the
data for the rebel layer or setting the
labels to the empty string for those who
that you don't want to plot it we talked
about and try both in the plot below
where you're only labeled ten random
points okay so we have empty costume
[Music]
and an empty costume would simply have
take the row names of the empty cast and
assign it to to a label so we can we can
map it with GG plots and then we'll
simply say points to label just take ten
random points right so if we so this is
not good right let's just give it some
more space to breathe okay so this is
kind of what we saw in the beginning
there are like a lot of a lot of points
of label and it's kind of overwhelming
so what if we just say that for the gym
text repeal layer we will just say well
the data should just be mg cars 2.2 okay
so now we we only have a subset of the
points that we're labeling which is what
we set out to achieve right but as we
can see there's the labels that we have
they don't overlap with each other but
they're still overlapping with with
with the points that we do not label
which is simply because the layer
doesn't know anything about the other
points so it cannot avoid overlapping
them so we want to avoid that and simply
make sure that that whatever whatever
label that we actually have in our plot
will stay out of the out of the points
that we have in the plot we can do
something else we can say well mg so
points the label is simply an integer
integer vector right and and here we
just say that well those those labels
that are not in this Institute vector we
simply assign an MC strings to that
right so we do that and we now we do not
modify the data and as we can see for
instance with the Hornets spot about it
actually moved away from this point to
the right I just realized you kind of
see my mouse so I'm sorry if I I've been
pointing to Hornets spot about with my
mouse and thought you all knew what I
was talking about and obviously you
don't but anyway in the last plot the
Hornets thought about was overlapping
with the point to the right of it and
using this approach we can kind of
circumvent this this overlapping which
is super nice so generally this is the
preferred way of doing things
explore the documentation from gym text
repel find a way to ensure that the
labels in the plot below only repels in
the vertical direction and we could look
into the documentation just to give you
a sense of all the different arguments
that are here so this is quite a
mouthful right a lot of it is for
styling styling the the things because
you can style the the line segment and
you can style the text and you can style
all different kind of things so in terms
of figuring out placement there is not
that many that many settings so what we
can see here is that direction we have
an argument called direction and we can
say well move things around in both
directions
or just move it in the X or Y directions
and what we were going for was sorry
what we were going for was to find a way
to to ensure that the labels in the plot
blow only repels in the vertical
direction that means that we should set
direction equals y see how it moves okay
so now we can see that the the different
labels are all kind of centered around
the the x position of the of the point
and they will just move up or down like
that I think I'll just take some
questions now one of them is they can do
repel be used to identify outliers
outliers as such is kind of a weird
concept in the sense that an outlier is
it's kind of a human construct in the
sense that you decide what's an outlier
is there is there's no way of telling
whether a point is actually truly an
outlier it is only an outlier you can
just explain why you why you label it an
outlier I know there are automatic ways
of detecting outliers all of these are
wrong in the sense that maybe it's not
an outlier maybe it's actually the the
interesting point that you should look
into so teacher repeal cannot be used to
identify the message I'm not sure
whether that's the question actually or
whether is it's for labeling outliers
and ensure it can be used for that but
but you're in control of figuring out
what outliers are
[Music]
to do so what can identify outliers not
just indicate an outlier exist again
these are all there are statistical
tests but but generally if you want to
figure out if something is an outlier
you need to go back and see how the data
was collected because that's the only
kind of way you can explain that an
outline exists we can see well this was
collected in a in a false manner then
it's a true outlier there are there are
great packages for identifying missing
data which is not really outlier but
kind of in the same sense that you want
to look into things that that may not be
there in your data
bye-bye NIC Gianni called Nonya which
provides some some extensions to ggplot2
for for showing missing data I know it's
tough directly what you asked for but I
was just it was just sprung to mind is
it possible to combine cheesy repellent
to the enemy so that the labels changes
as the animation goes yes it is you can
you can certainly use act eg animate
will generally work with any well
behaved extension package and you repel
as it will behave the extension package
so so it works but the way that Gigi
rappel works is by kind of using a
spring embedded layout kind of forcing
things away from each other and as Gigi
animate kind of moves along you might
have like some very drastic jumps and in
how the labels move around because this
this spring embedding is calculated for
each each frame separately and if
there's huge changes to the underlying
position of the data then you will end
up with with some drastic changes in
where the labels gets flooded so it's
kind of a hit or miss sometimes it work
nicely sometimes it doesn't so that's
just kind of how it is okay let's get
back to the
exercises so Gigi Faust comes with four
different types of markjames
try them all out in the code below okay
so this this is this symbol simply a
plug and as I talked about there are
different mark gems we can try this one
it's dead and we can see well we get a
rectangle and as we can see the
rectangular kind of goes out of the the
plotting area and this is because the
expansion of the rectangle happens after
the rendering so so it's a fixed size
like I think it's two millimeters or
something like that so the the extent of
the plot has no way of has no way of
reacting to this expansion so we can
just look into some of the different we
have this expand sitting here if we said
that's know for instance we have no
extent expansion but as we can see we
actually have like things lying lying on
the on the border which doesn't look
super nice so so this is the reason why
there's default and expansion applied
also you can see that we have a rounding
of the corners per default and you can
also just turn that off by setting the
radius to zero which will just which
reference the corner radius of the
market you so there's a lot of things we
can do with it let's just see we also
have Jim Mac circle which will again
this will forcefully be a true circle
which means that a lot of it may end up
being outside of the plot area if it's
if it's placed in the corner of it
that's just how it is and if if you end
up with the in that situation that your
best bet is simply either not use a
circle or simply expand the the limits
of your of your axis to accommodate for
it one other thing that you could do
which we actually didn't talk about last
time is that one thing you can do in the
new coordinate system is that you
turn off clipping which means that
things that lies outside of the panel
will not be be clipped so if we do that
we can see well it doesn't really
improve the look but but you can
actually see that it is still there the
last mark Jim is called Mack hull and as
we can see it will draw by default it
will draw a concave hull which means
it's not a convex hull as we as we use I
used to think about but this can be it
can be set so if we if we set it to ten
for instance it will be like on a convex
hull and we can make it more or less
follow around the points by by
decreasing it so so setting it to one or
maybe let's try to such a 0.5 to see if
we can make it dip even more let's just
see what happens I love change anyway
you can you can play with the concavity
argument to simply figure out how how
closely it should follow the the border
of of your data one thing we haven't
really seen here like as I talked about
you can have multiple multiple different
marks in one layer and it will make sure
that the labels will not overlap is just
go back to this one so let's just we'll
just ignore the labels for now and say
we'll say fill equals two
[Music]
so now it actually no this doesn't look
super nice to say let's use the whole
actually still not using looking super
nice but this is simply because there's
a lot of overlap between the different
groups so so that's just how it is but
anyway if you if you just assign a film
then then will behave kind of like
whatever you you would normally see that
that you you'll have multiple different
different groups and here they will
overlap so in that sense you can you can
also set the label to be to be gear for
instance and and we will have the labels
placed there as well so you don't need
labels you actually also don't need you
don't need the markings as well so if we
just say group equals that and say so
now we just is this kind of nonsensical
but but just to show you can have one
without the other if you want to you can
either have the labels and you can have
the grouping and closings and you're
gonna have both of them at the same time
right so there's a lot of possibility
built into this and sometimes you want
to have like create a big group of
different things actually I think just a
maintenance so the first the first plot
I showed in this section actually had oh
there we have it sorry now we have it so
so this is obviously made with with GG
force and the gym mark ellipse as we can
see we have we are marking a big area of
points that has a general interest and
then we are actually marking and kind of
an outlier that that sits within this
area but it's not part of that group
right so so you can you can do a lot of
fancy things and love
start selling using this right okay
let's get back on track sir for this
short division and there we are okay
we're kind of back on track now okay
before I go into network plus I just
want to briefly say that annotations is
a lot of things and here I'm only
talking about text annotation one other
package that well will just briefly
mention and I think you should look into
is one called Gigi highlight which
allows you to kind of color specific
points based on some conditions so you
have you you have your general G plot to
code and then you then you simply say
well right now with all this this code I
want to make everything that does not
fulfill this condition transparent or
whatever or I want to mute the colors of
everything that does not follow this
this condition right so so this is
another type of annotation way to kind
of draw attention to certain parts of
your area and did you highlight along
with for instance Gigi force is
fantastic to to kind of draw attention
to aspects of your visualization that
you you want the reader or viewer to
take note of because you can still see
the underlying data but it's very clear
and you're directing the the eye of the
viewer in a very clear way in saying
well there's all this data but look at
this this is the thing that you should
really focus on so there's at the moment
there's a fantastic amount of different
annotation functions and generally as we
talked about a lot of storytelling
functions build into G plot 2 in the
extension system that allows you to not
need to go into Adobe Illustrator or
whatever but can actually create
publication where the figures directly
encode
without any any type of post-processing
[Music]
let's see yes I think we'll just move on
I'm sorry I can't take all of the
questions as it is that's just how it's
going to be I can see that the time is
already slipping so so we'll hastily
move on so networks this is another
thing of mine do you plan to was was
generally built for a particular data
and ggplot2 was potentially one of the
first packages to really enforce this
idea of Tidy data even before tiny data
exists as a existed as as a name but you
have to keep in mind that this is really
just an API decision like there's
there's nothing in the underlying theory
of the grammar of graphics that says
that the data has to be tabular so so
networks for instance is very very badly
represented by a single tabular data
source you can however represented as
two tabular data sources one describing
the inches of your network and one
describing the notes so if you if you
haven't really looked into in some
networks in general notes are the things
that are being connected and edges are
the things are the connections between
them other names can be inverses which
is the same as nodes and links which is
the same as the same as edges and there
are a few others as well so there are
there are multiple packages that tries
to do network visualization or ad
network capabilities into ggplot2 g GL
AGG network Jim net GD 3 GD DAC so
that's that's quite a lot jeez your led
the network into Jim net has tried to
kind of make make a general approach to
what I would call Note edge diagram some
will call it help all diagrams because
they usually end up looking horrible
like a mess of things this is not the
fault of these packages this is just
like this visualization type is it's not
suited for for large amount of data GG
tree and GG tag are more specialized so
so GG tree as a package meant for
creating especially evolutionary trees
but in general also all kinds of other
trees tree dendrograms and so on ours
also network diagrams and in the sense
GG tag is specialized in to creating
directed acyclic graphs which is a kind
of also kind of a tree but it allows
multiple parents now I'm not going to
talk about any of these I'll talk about
ggrf which is another of my packages so
gif is I'm sure most of the other
authors of these packages will agree is
I think the the most the biggest package
when it comes to creating networks in
the sense that it provides the most
capabilities and let's just dive into it
G giraffe comes kind of hand-in-hand
with another package called tidy graph
which is the package that that allows
for a tidy approach to to network
modifications in the same like it's kind
of a deep lie a plus plan plus per kind
of package just made for networks and so
it allows using mutate and inducing
filter and whatnot on network objects so
just to show off we'll start by creating
a network we call graph and so this is a
data set called secory which is
friendships between pupils in the sakura
karate club which is a kind of like iris
for network data and we calculate a
social clique for each of the nodes
using a tidy graph function group info
map so we're using an community
detection algorithm called info map
which simply assigns an integer to
specify the membership
of different to different groups right
now to plot this using a gif instead of
using ggplot to start with we will
reduce ggrf and pass it in this this
graph object and now we'll just specify
the itches and the notes separately
because they're kind of different
separate data sources and they need to
be treated separately so we say giraffe
plus gh link which is simply just a
straight line that connects notes that
has an edge between them and Jim note
points which is simply just kind of at
the point Jim and we'll color by by
click and there you have it we have we
have our network plot now it may look
like with the start with the ggrf call
that the teacher F is something that
that kind of sits by itself but but
really what we're working with this is
simply a ggplot object in the gif
function system as you plot two objects
it just does additional work under the
hood that allows everything to work
nicely but but it is underneath it all
it's still a ggplot2 object and we can
see that by by looking at it well we can
still use the standard ggplot geum's
that were used to so here we're taking
from GG force Jim Marco and use that to
color in different clicks so it's it's
kind of powerful in the sense that it
defines something that is specific to
networks but it's still just ggplot
under the hood and that means that it
can also be used with patchwork it can
be used with GG anime the computers with
all these these are the things that that
works together in the extended universe
so that's quite nice further ggrf
understands more or less all the
different objects that that are
represented as as networks inside off so
for instance the output of h plus is an
H plus object which defines the
dendrogram
and and this can be understood as a
graph object by ggrf well underneath it
all it will it will convert them to the
tiny graph representation but tidy graph
understands almost everything about
networks and in R so you can be
confident that most of the things that
you that you usually work with which our
networks can be used directly with ggrf
so here we're just saying well we create
a hierarchical clustering of iris and
and we cut this with IRA with ggrf using
a new edge we could use another cubic
elbow which will draw kind of straight
angles but he would just kind of like
this this fancy organic look of a bit of
rounded corner and again we'll add Jim
note pine and we'll just ask Jim note
we'll just add points only to to the
Leafs of this this telegram that's mean
the terminal nodes of this tree now the
leaf didn't exist in our input data but
different types of layout will we'll
kind of add additional information to
your data source during computation so
this is all described inside inside the
documentation but when you're creating a
when you're when you're drawing a
dendrogram you can be sure that there
will be a leaf variable that says well
is this node and leaf or not and and we
can just use that and then assign it to
the field aesthetic that that exists for
all the different ggrf geum's let's just
take a quick look at the questions how
can i improve the rendering quality of
my plus in our studio my guess is that
you are on Windows
much in I can't pronounce your your last
name and on Windows the default device
is horrible and it
horrible and TV or our studio is is
simply using the default PNG device to
render its plus so it will also look
horrible
one way of getting away with that is to
not use windows but that's not a really
compelling argument to switch from
windows but you can change I think you
can change the default the default PNG
device by setting a certain option
inside with the options function I can't
really go into it up but you can look
into how can you how can I change how
can I change the whether I'm using cairo
or the the standard windows windows
rendering and so on and if you set it to
cairo then you will get much nicer plots
and that's just how it is i can i can
say that that our studio is looking into
improving that because we don't like how
it is so we'll probably you'll probably
see changes to the to the graphic device
in our studio within the next couple of
i don't know you a half year a year
something like that maybe so so that's
one way but it's it's kind of annoying
that if you're in Windows the default
just simply looks horrible but that's
just a set state of affair ytg force I I
don't know if it's a question to to to
the name but that was just me thinking
it look sounds good okay is there a way
for regular layers to access the edges -
yes there is
so when you look at the when you look at
the code up here we don't specify that
um we don't specify whether you're using
its data or no data and the different in
the different layers it's just simply
follows that gmh pin will access the s
data and you'll note point will access
the note data
[Music]
am i muted can no one hear me okay
people can still hear me maybe your
computer audio is muted instead I don't
know I take it that that my mic is
working fine okay and so here we don't
really need to specify anything in in a
different layers but if we want to
specify have a have itches drawn by by
some other layer that does not
automatically grab the s data you can do
that by it is passing in the correct
function to the data argument I won't
show it here but I won't show it here
but but you can get around that okay
okay people seem to be hearing me so I
think it's a it's a fluke and maybe some
network problems anyway let's um let's
get in through some of the exercises so
okay most Network+ are defined by a
layout algorithm which takes the network
structure and calculate a position for
each node the layout algorithm is global
and is set as part of the teacher F the
default is also a layout which respect
the network object and try to choose a
sensible layout yeah so oops
I need to do that up here oh my god
there we go sorry about that
okay so as we can see in this this plot
the notes kind of just gets placed
somewhere and they get placed in the
sense that you get kind of an overview
of your network structure but but you
should be aware that this is just kind
of a heuristic placement of the nodes
there are no true placement of the nodes
and there's a lot of different layout
algorithm that just kind of different
types of way of positioning the nodes
and none of them are actually kind of
true which is one of the the big
problems in general with with these
types of network plus you tend to look
way too much into the location of the
nodes
even though that these are kind of just
a byproduct of the layout algorithm if
someone ever shows you kind of a plot
like this maybe even with with bigger
even with bigger bigger network data and
someone says well because we can clearly
see a cluster in this area then then be
skeptical at the very beginning of that
sentence because you cannot infer
clusters by simply looking at a network
plot anyway that was my my big my big
setup there so there is so for instance
we can say that we want to have a layout
that is based on I just know by hot
different types of layouts and we can
see the the
Emily algorithm is okay someone is
keeping stars is acting up so who is
chemists eyes
I don't know how to ban people I am
sorry
just a minute I'm sorry for that this
this dream in general is intended to be
a very very nice place for people to be
so please don't be idiots I'm sorry I
have to say that but I have no idea
I just removed his missus that doesn't
worry
okay sorry I will just ignore the chat
for a while I am sorry if things are
acting up in there and people are being
idiots I kind of patrol the chat while
I'm talking so okay let's get back on
track so as you can see there are
different types of layouts that we can
that we can try out and no it should
just be said that none of these are true
like you can you can try different out
and see what's aesthetically pleasing
for you or which kind of best tells the
story but they are all kind of just
[Music]
they're all just kind of byproducts of
an underlying algorithm that is not
objectively true okay so anyway sorry I
got a bit distracted on what was
happening on the chat I will just ignore
it for now there are many ways to draw
edges as well so let's just have a look
at at this plus over here here we have a
high school data set which shows
friendship in a high school as it
evolves over two different years and
this means that there are multiple H is
going between the same two notes and we
cannot see that here because all the H
is kind of just overlap in the same way
but there are a lot of different ways as
as to draw edges we thought you miss
link before and here as well and we saw
it you may spend and there are a lot of
other things so for instance th parallel
will take parallel edges and kind of
just shift in a bit aside again this is
not a beautiful plot but just as you can
see how it works it will it will take
multiple inches and kind of spread them
out the same thing can be can be done
with the image fan for instance which
instead of drawing them as parallel will
kind of just give it different bins
instead so just to show you there are a
lot of different ways that you can
you can draw your edges as well and
faceting works in ggrf as well as a
dozen ggplot2 but you should not use the
building you should not use your
building facets from ggplot2 because
they they assume a single data source
and that doesn't really work instead we
can say that I want to face it
as to the edges and I want to facet them
by I think it's called the Year column
and there we go we have the the subplot
that corresponds to the 1957 and another
plot corresponding to two friendships in
95 58 so again ggrf allows you to do a
lot of the things that you will
generally want to do in ggplot2
okay so let's get back to the
presentation
okay the last thing I'm going to talk
about when it comes to two extensions is
looks theming is one of the things that
is one of the easiest things to extend
we talked about how we can do a lot of
things with themes last time and there
is a lot of options with extension
packages this provides a lot of
different looks that you can just
piggyback on so if you don't have like
this aesthetic or artistic gene where
you want to look into all of these these
different settings that the theme
provides then you can simply look into
some of all these nice theme package and
just pick a pleasing one you don't have
to be original to to create nice nice
plus right so these what that you sorry
what you should think about is that a
theme is often covered with a coupled
with a colors
so if you change this team theme the the
color scale that you use for color and
fill will usually look out of place if
you don't update it to change with it
and a lot of these packages comes with
with scales that fill in color scales
that work quite nicely along with them
so one a great starting point to simply
make very very pleasing pleasing plots
is the HRP are themes which provides a
very very simple very elegant theme
which is a fantastic starting ground for
for simply just changing it a bit if you
want to or simply just have a very
elegant theme it provides this theme
Epsom and also provides a couple of
others and it provides color scales and
feel scales to go along with it there
are also others more to the front side I
would say for instance if you want to
create if you if you look back and wish
for the times when when the classic
excel existed you can replicate it here
and then you will look at the default
gray background with with joy in your
eyes and that is kind of it I don't want
to go into the exercise for the themes
because they're not that interesting and
we are running short on time so I'll
just wrap up a bit
this ended up taking way longer than I
expected so thank you for hanging in
there the last part is kind of a talky
part without any exercises and I want to
kind of go in and into the promise of
the idea of drawing anything with with
ggplot2 so as we can see there's a lot
you can do with ggplot2 and there's a
lot of things that that you cannot do
just with ggplot2 but when you pull in
the whole extension system you
you can really draw a lot of things but
the gram of traffic as it is it's not
just for for creating graphs also for
deconstructing them as well so when
someone is presenting a craft to you you
can use this idea of the grammar of
traffic to kind of break it down and
better understand what's actually going
on and hopefully make sure that you're
not that it is not cheating on you and
that you're actually understanding and
in the right way
what you should keep in mind is that the
grammar is actually ambiguous and that
is that it's okay that there's a lot of
ways to deconstruct a graph and think
about a graph and one way we can look at
that is to go back to our fantastic pie
chart so so just let us think a bit
about how does a pie chart fit into the
grammar of graphic we haven't really
looked at it since the very first slide
in part one and so when we're presented
with this how should we kind of
deconstruct it in a grammar of graphics
sense what are the geums what are the
stats one of the course what are the
data these kind of things is things
something that that you can benefit a
lot of thing
not from Byam by looking at the like
looking at the plot and thinking about
where everything comes from
so if we want to create a pie chart with
ggplot2 well one way of doing it is that
well we start by by creating some data
this is just an unsecured nonsensical
data but one way we could do it is by
starting by creating this the stacked
bar chart where everything is in the
same same place and stacked on top of
each other and then we can apply a polar
coordinate system to it and then
suddenly we have a pie chart right so
this is something that fits very nicely
within then ggplot2 and this is one of
the things that that
you know Wilkinson naturally ended up
[Music]
ended up showing this this first chapter
where he talked about what is a pie
chart this is well a pie chart is a
polar coordinate system stacked bar
chart in the polar coordinate system
right and we can just chase a bit of the
themes and we have have this look that
we ended up having well so a pie chart
is a stacked bar chart in a in a polar
coordinate system right well not
necessarily because you can also see
that saying that a pie chart is is a
which GM coupled with a step for
calculating radians now this looks this
sounds quite weird but but this is
equally a true true grammar
representation of a pie a pie chart so
if we're using this is from Jiji false
again as I said this is just a package
with a lot of different things a
grab-bag of source and if for instance
it provides this geum akbar which which
allows you to draw witches and we just
said the inner radius to be 0 so it's a
it's a full witch and then we use the
the PI stat which will calculate the
radiance needed for pie chart and then
we'll just draw it with chord fix
because we want the true circular
representation and we can just provide
the same like theme differences and we
end up in the same way so what is true
well none of them are uniquely true and
it's just to kind of show that when you
have a when you have a plot and you
decompose it you can you can end up
going in different direction and that is
ok some of the things some of the the
the choices that you make when you
decompose it actually can influence what
you can do with the with the plot that
you end up creating so for instance if
you have a pie chart in akola polar
coordinate system you cannot really have
exploded wedges if that is your fancy or
if it's a fancy of your of your bus
because you usually not want to make up
with explode the wages and the reason
for that is that that you it's very very
difficult to make linear transformations
of the genomes when when everything is
based on this polar coordinate system so
if you really really really want to make
exploded wishes in your pie chart you
need to do that in a Cartesian
coordinate system and then you need to
think about a pie chart as as a wedge
tomb with a with a pie stand applied to
it another example of this is that when
you look at the Geum histogram or a
histogram then in general you will think
about it as a packraft with a with a
bidding sted applied to it
this also simply has a Geum histogram
shortcut and in GG plot 2 and this is
how we usually construct histograms in R
or with ggplot2 at least now it can also
be something else for instance you can
you can use a pinning scale instead and
simply use jimpad directly because then
the scale is actually bidding bidding
these things and as you can see it
dramatically or not maybe not
dramatically but it changes the look of
of what you end up with because the
bidding scale has has different X's
ticks so so you'll actually have ticks
between your between your bin paths
which for some applications can be super
nice and for other it's just over
plotting right so this is just kind of
teases about what you can do when you
sit down and think about well what this
plot type how is that represented by the
grammar of graphics and there are
multiple routes to take and and there's
a lot of different different things to
consider and just the mental gymnastics
of trying to translate things into
Instagram of graphic is it's really
really powerful in the sense that it
allows you to get more acquainted with
the data that it's actually being shown
to you so it's a very very good thing to
do and one way that you can challenge
yourself and I will I hope I can
challenge you to do that
is to look into this this project called
tidy Tuesday it has it has some some
github repository it has a hashtag on
Twitter and also has a shiny shiny app
so what is time Tuesday well the idea is
that every Tuesday the tiny Tuesday
group releases the data set and then
kind of invites everyone to explore it
in their own way with usually with
visualizations in some sort and and this
results in a huge amount of different
approaches to looking at the same sort
of data and I think it's a fantastic way
to to see what other peoples are doing
with with the same data set and what
other people are doing with with ggplot2
or whatever else they're using so just
to show what some people are doing with
ggplot2 this is Jake cow looking into a
dataset of different songs and and and
what kind of characteristics these
different songs have so this is this is
GG plug to plug right out of Gd plot to
and I think it's an amazingly beautiful
visualization that kind of focuses on a
couple of songs and how they relate to
the huge amount of data that is there
now one thing that is super nice with
the title Tuesday is that a lot of
people actually makes their scripts
available so you can look at the
visualization you can kind of try to
guess what they're doing and then you
can you can get back and look into the
the into the script and and figure out
well what did they actually do was I
correct or what I have done it in a
different way which kind of extensions
did they use and so on now the same data
set also resulted in this visualization
by Citrix share where he instead looked
into the two hip up and how it kind of
evolved in the air and Spotify and as
you can see this is not a single
visualization he has arranged a lot of
different visualization I think he was
using cow plot but I'll
give him for that and created this this
morsel of a storytelling approach to it
all just to reiterate this is the same
data set more kind of an artistic taste
looking into three different playlists
and see well how do they relate to each
other which which areas are they are
they focusing on when we kind of look
into the songs that they that they're in
the playlists and just to show first of
all what you can do with with Gigi
animate but also generally that doesn't
have to be static visualization so this
is not the same data set this is this is
static right now it shouldn't be static
maybe I need to push a button otherwise
you must take my word for it oh there we
go
so this is a Gigi animate animation
where he's not looking at the same data
set issues looking another dataset
regarding school diversity just sure
well you can do it you can find anything
in this title just a project and you can
really get inspired by a lot of talented
people that kind of just sits down and
think about some some data and and
creates amazing plus and for for
learning ggplot2 I think it's an amazing
project even if you don't end up
participating it it's simply just seeing
what other people are doing okay we'll
be wrapping up now so just to say if if
you want more about ggplot2 and in
general my name is Joe stationed in
general there's a book ggplot2 elegant
graphics for data analysis which is
written by mainly by Headley Wickham and
it is now a free book as well so you can
go into this ggplot2 slash book talk and
have it all and we're building up to a
third a third edition now which will be
released at some point but it will
continue to be free as it is one thing
that we will look into adding to the
spook is a lot more text about how
actually to create extensions so if you
have if I piqued your interest in
creating your own extensions then
there'll be a lot of information there
about how to get started with that there
are two other books that I want to
recommend when it comes to data
visualization one is from Karen Healy
which is data visualization a practical
introduction which is also available for
free but generally if you have the money
then support the authors of course which
is focusing on how to use ggplot2
specifically to create create machine
stations that you can use in your daily
work and the other is by class we'll get
one of the core members of the g2
development teams which is called
fundamentals of data visualization now
this doesn't actually contain ggplot2
code a lot of the visualization should
look into or look in there or seen there
sorry this is from ggplot2 but the book
focuses more on theory and the and like
what should you think about when you
create and design visualization so he
decided to remove the code I think he's
been working on on a repository where
it's actually showing the code as well
so you can also have the code that goes
with the book okay a lot of the
extension packages that I've talked
about also has web pages where you can
find both tutorial articles and and
references to the different
functionality that's in there so you can
you can go into there and read more as
well and of course also explore the
extension package website or gallery
where you can look into even a greater
expanse of different extensions so this
is it
thank you very much for for attending
this ended up being way longer than I
expected so thank you for keeping up
with me I thought it would be one hour
shorter but this is the this is the end
of the workshop I'll probably not be I
don't have anything planned for for next
week or whatever this was kind of
had this lying around and in memory so I
thought I would be using this corona
virus care according to to just get it
out there and educate so I don't have
anything planned now and maybe I will
I'll look into adding more maybe
focusing in on some of the extension
packages that I talked about but stay
tuned maybe they will come over at some
point but until then thank you and take
care in these times it's purely us out
there have a good day